foreign
let's go to Ashley in Columbia Missouri
what's up Ashley
hey John how's it going what's happening
I'm doing great how about you
doing okay doing okay awesome I'm a
little nervous oh good grief have you
heard the show before Oh Yeah Ashley
I'm not good at this I know you have
nothing to be nervous about you're good
what's up
so
um I had a baby back in October all
right is congratulations in order
yes yes awesome congratulations very
cool thank you thank you
um but and so it's my second one
um it was my first one I experienced
like postpartum anxiety but with this
one I'm experiencing like the depression
and
maybe the anxiety with it
um I just I don't know how to navigate
that like through my marriage through
any of it like it's kind of new to us
and so
um I made a doctor's appointment to try
and get on some medication
um so we just got that taken care of
um but I just don't know like see you
you've already have you been put on
something
yes like I haven't been able to start it
has been fighting a little bit of a
tummy bug but what would they give you
oh gosh
um that's all right that's all right
that's all right
um so I'm not sure
if nobody's told you this I'm sorry that
I'm the first guy to tell you this
anxiety and depression are on the same
trend line
okay they're just different ways your
body's trying to take care of you
and
um this is a crass way to say this but
like having a baby is a human explosion
okay your hormones are all over
everywhere
and one of the worst demons about PPD
postpartum depression is or postpartum
anxiety whatever however your body is
trying to take care of you all the
switches and levers are all goofed up
all over the place
and everybody has a different
um
a different path back to homeostasis or
some people are forever different and
that's the that's the beauty of it all
and it's disorienting right it feels
like you are lost at sea
exactly right and so
I want to First applaud you
because tell me if I'm off here
there is something completely unnerving
when your body is saying I need these
like I I should be enjoying these kids
these are my babies they're healthy
they're this my husband's great all
those stories
and then you go to war with your body
you get really frustrated then you get
down on it or you get spun up on it and
then you start to feel crazy and then
people around you start saying why don't
you just cheer up or why don't you just
slow down or won't you just rest and
it's like oh I hadn't thought of that
genius right and now it sort of feels
like you're against everybody
is that fair
okay absolutely okay
what in your current life oh so before I
get there
I want to applaud you for having the
courage to go talk to a doctor
my first note when you start talking was
call your OB GYN and go be honest with
how you're feeling okay what are some of
your
um as comfortable as you are saying
about loud what are some of your low
thoughts
um they'd be better off without me they
get the life insurance money
um they
do they really need me you know like
um gosh
um
I'm a horrible mother because I should
be enjoying every moment with them but
yet for some reason I can't
get past things I can't let things go I
can't stop worrying about the smallest
of things
um
it's like the worry and things like that
just steal the Joy from the day I can
get caught up on something so small and
insignificant that it just tears my
whole day apart my whole week apart
um what have you tried
well when you say tried what do you mean
what have I tried like between your
first baby and your second baby what if
you what are some things you've tried to
do
um
getting on a good multi
if I just pretty much everything but
medication okay all right um I'm gonna
give you a couple other
um
things I want you to try is that cool
first thing I want you to do is to just
carry a note card in your pocket
and you're how old is how old's your new
baby
he's four months old yeah you can like
when you're like babies under like a
year you can wear any kind of awesome
zipper Class B things no matter what
nobody's gonna judge you right so I want
you in one of your zipper Class B bag
things I want you to have a note card
okay
and I want you to have a pen
and anytime you think the words I can't
or I should
I want you to write those down
and my guess is very quickly you're
going to realize there's those the cants
and the shoulds are going to circle
around each other
in one or two or maybe three very
specific things okay
these thoughts feel like they're coming
at you at a million miles an hour and
they're all around you like a video game
right and you're trying to shoot them
all down they're just coming and coming
and coming and it starts to overwhelm
you and then your body just says I'm out
yeah right what I want you to do is
begin to take capture to capture them to
take ownership of them okay I'm gonna
write them down I can't even enjoy my
babies today
is your body's way of saying hey we need
some rest
I should be able to fill in the blank is
your body telling you
hey let's ask for help today
and I know Instagram says mom should be
doing all these things
great my body's not there today
thank God I've got a husband who's gonna
show up
you see what I'm saying I want to begin
to take to every time you say the words
I can't every time you you think the
words I should I want you to write them
down and begin to look at those okay
and ask yourself what is my body trying
to tell me
the second thing is
where in your life
do you feel unsafe
alone in my thoughts I would say
um
I don't physically feel unsafe or
anything like that here's another way of
asking where in your life do you feel
not listened to or unheard
oh man
I think maybe
I fear
talking to people because I don't want
to be a burden on them there you go
that's the magic word I I don't talk
okay
and so maybe your body is finding fear
in those who love you most
because somewhere along the way
you thought reaching out and telling
your husband hey I need this today and
it's different than what I needed
yesterday
that you're gonna burden him because he
works hard and he's probably tired too
oh yeah appreciate it and I'm just gonna
Circle this up I'm not gonna call my
mother-in-law who's offered to come stay
I'm not going to call my mom because I
don't want to bother them they got their
own lives
and you said it best
at the core that story is I'm a burden
my kids will be better off without me my
husband would be better off without me
I'm just dragging the boat down
Fair yeah
Allen Allen head yeah
I need you to hear me so clearly
that's not true
feelings are incredible traffic signals
they are terrible uh destinations
and so I want you to rest and anytime
you feel like a burden
remember my voice saying you're not
and so then
the next question you have to ask
yourself is what are you going to do not
what are you gonna think you think
enough for about 15 people don't you
next question is what are you gonna do
okay
I would really really love to see you
get a group of grown-up friends away
from both babies at least once a week
that you can go be a grown-up with
place for you cool
sometimes Bible studies and sometimes
co-workers
that's a dangerous combination but if it
worked for you incredible that's awesome
okay
will you go will you commit to going for
the next I don't know six weeks seven
weeks eight weeks
okay
the greatest gift you could give your
kids
is for you to go be with other adults
for a while
and to come back a little more at peace
and a little more whole than having a
two human beings treat your body like a
jungle gym and a filling station
the fair yeah
I also it's going to be hard to say
these things out loud
I want you to sit down with your husband
and start these with these words
the story I'm telling myself is
that if I ask you for some more help
you're gonna leave
a story I'm telling myself is if I tell
you what I need you're going to do it
anyway at the expense of your own health
then I'm scared to tell you what I
actually need because I don't want to be
a burden
now you know your husband better than I
do if you sat down and told them that
what would his response be
will you give
this is from a a dad of two young kids
myself
will you give him the greatest honor and
gift and letting him love his wife
during this time
instead of considering yourself a burden
consider yourself giving him the
greatest gift you can give any modern
male which is the illusion he's taking
care of his wife
how's it sound
yeah
good
if you can't do it for yourself
hopefully you can get there soon
but do it for him allow him to
participate
okay
all of this circles back to this one
important thing you are not a burden
you're a gift
always know that the end of that
sentence I'm a burden my kids will be
better off without me the ending of that
sentence is always that's not true
okay and I don't know if you are I want
to take this from you the first time I
the only time but I did it for a while
when I sat down and took medication my
but my buddy was at my doctor he was a
close friend of mine and so he could
speak some truth directly to me probably
a little more direct than he would to
just a normal patient and I'm probably
more stubborn than the normal patient
um I sat at my kitchen table with the
open package and I wept I just cried I
thought it was such a failure such a
loser
it's kind of how I feel yeah all right
like my last resort you know yeah and
hey here's the deal good for you it was
my last resort too
and you didn't have too much pride and
you didn't have too much
um
ego
to not go tell your doctor the truth
okay
so know this it's not forever
and
sometimes we just need some help turning
the lights on or sometimes we need some
help turning the Alarm Systems down so
that we can sit in front of those we
love and say I need some help so that
I can have the energy to get up and go
take a walk outside so that I can have
the courage to go hang out with some
friends even though I feel like I'm
failing my kids if I leave them for two
hours which you're not
okay the greatest gift I gave my wife
and my little young son at the time and
then my daughter down the road was I
went and got myself the care that I
needed
and then I didn't stop there because
medication's not going to quote unquote
fix it it's going to provide you a path
so that you can go do the things that
are going to make you well
that makes sense
yeah I'm really really proud of you
thank you
so what's your next step
ah
get with my girls yes on Monday nights
and
put down with my husband and
talk to him
dude you're awesome and the third thing
I'm going to put out there is promise me
you'll always tell your doctor the truth
and be in close contact if you ever ever
ever
start crossing over in some really
darker thoughts okay
promise thank you promise
awesome hey you're one of the braver
ones I will talk to this week you
probably want to Brave everyone someone
talk to you this month
um
I'm proud of you proud of you
by the way one quick last thing sorry I
know everybody's fading it out
um you may want to check in with your
doctor and ask for some hormone panels
and some hormone testing I just thought
of that as I'm letting you go here
um that may be worth your time just even
if you're just getting a baseline to see
what things are going to look like in
two months and three months and five
months uh ask your doctor if there's any
sort of blood work or any sort of
hormone testing that would help too to
identify some of the chaotic the chaos
okay